guerre en Ukraine crise climatique
l'agriculture peut-elle continuer à nous
nourrir cette année les rendements pour
certains légumes et céréales ont chuté
alors quelle place pour la Touraine et
ses 300 000 hectares de terre ont fait
le point ce soir avec notre invité on
soit Henri Frémont bonsoir vous êtes
président de la chambre de l'agriculture
d'Indre-et-Loire et si on parle de
sécurité alimentaire c'est le terme
c'est notamment parce que ce sujet était
au cœur d'une conférence ce matin dans
vos locaux en présence du ministre de
l'Agriculture Marc fenault alors c'est
vrai que la guerre en Ukraine et la
sécheresse sont révélées certaines
faiblesses de l'agriculture française le
prix de l'alimentation des bêtes et des
matières premières augmentent et dans le
même temps la production baisse à cause
de la sécheresse pour vous il faut
produire plus chez nous mais est-ce que
c'est vraiment possible alors bien
évidemment qu'il faut produire plus et
mieux il faut bien avoir ça en tête et
oui chez nous c'est possible on a la
chance d'être dans un département et
même la France où on encore à l'abri des
catastrophes climatiques donc on a une
capacité à produire on a le foncier on a
les compétences et les hommes pour cette
production pour alimenter notre
population alors plus ça veut dire quoi
quels sont vos pistes de réflexion qui
sont dégagées de cette conférence donc
ce matin
avec le ministre Marc féno alors le
sujet de la conférence c'était autour de
la sécurité le conférencier nous
expliquait et si pendant la période
covid les camions s'étaient arrêtés donc
on aurait retrouvé très rapidement des
rayons de grande surface vides puisque
on sait qu'ils n'ont pas de stock donc
voilà donc l'idée c'est de dire de
produire c'est bien mais comment on peut
faire pour que sur nos territoires alors
on peut faire à l'échelle d'un
département comme le nôtre on arrive à
être un peu plus autonome en termes
d'alimentation aujourd'hui on estime
qu'on est autonome en alimentation en
hauteur de 12% dans le département et
pour ça il faut donc nourrir les animaux
l'alimentation c'est aussi
l'alimentation animale d'abord vous
demander à produire plus de protéines
c'est bien ça voilà pour pour nourrir il
faut des protéines d'ailleurs c'est
aussi au cœur du sujet pour
l'alimentation humaine parce qu'on parle
de protéines animales qui pourraient
être remplacées par des protéines
végétales donc les animaux sont dans le
même cas elles ont à peu près toujours
mangé des protéines des protéines
végétales protéines sont importées
aujourd'hui notamment du soja d'Amérique
du Sud
la déforestation de la forêt amazonienne
on y est quand même un petit peu pour
quelque chose puisque notre soja arrive
à des prix défi en toute con toute
concurrence d'Amérique du Sud et puis
pour une agriculture locale le ministre
marfeno suggère et bien de voilà de
valoriser les produits fabriqués en
France on va l'écouter justement cet été
ce matin
je me souviens d'une pub qui était nos
emplettes sur nos emplois la vérité pour
moi nos emplettes sont notre
souveraineté et la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est la première des
souverainetés vous n'êtes pas libre si
vous n'êtes pas capable de vous
alimenter avec les productions de votre
territoire et pour qu'on active il faut
faire le geste de dire que
l'alimentation il faut se tourner
d'abord de les producteurs locaux donc
c'est un sujet c'est pour ça que les
plans alimentaires territoriaux qu'on a
construit avec les collectivités qu'on
veut développer dans les lois égalim la
volonté de faire monter en puissance des
produits locaux et de qualité dans les
cantines dans la restauration scolaire
comme on dit tout ça c'est des éléments
qui viennent contribuer à une prise de
conscience collective sur la valeur de
l'alimentation et la valeur de nos
produits locaux la valeur de
l'alimentation la valeur des produits
locaux une agriculture durable et locale
c'est aussi des prix plus élevés ça vous
plaidez depuis longtemps maintenant sur
le fait que les consommateurs doivent
accepter ces hausse de prix bien
évidemment aujourd'hui on a imaginé une
agriculture et une alimentation au
niveau mondial en faisant produire dans
les régions où c'était le plus économe
où ça coûtait le moins cher possible
justement pour le pouvoir d'achat du
consommateur et avec ce sujet de la
relocalisation et de la consommation
d'une agriculture locale bien évidemment
que ça coûtera un petit peu plus cher et
il faut que le il faut que le
consommateur
joue le jeu puisque on critiquait par
rapport aux produits locaux les grandes
surfaces en un temps en disant mais il y
a que des produits étrangers aujourd'hui
les grandes surfaces proposent à peu
près 30% de produits locaux donc au
consommateur de jouer le jeu oui ça sera
un petit peu plus cher on peut pas vous
dire le contraire malheureusement mais
c'est c'est un enjeu de sécurité
alimentaire et de sécurité tout court
que faire face à la sécheresse les
productions de patates par exemple
diminue moins 15 - 30 %, est-ce qu'il y
a des pistes aujourd'hui alors autour de
la sécheresse il y a tout le travail que
nous on peut faire en termes agronomique
pour nos sols puisqu'on sait que quand
on augmente le taux de matière organique
de l'école c'est la capacité de de
stocker de l'eau qui existe après on a
la recherche variétale quelque part on
sait aujourd'hui travailler
génétiquement les plantes pour qu'elles
soient plus résistantes à la sécheresse
les OGM des alors pas forcément des OGM
mais de la recherche génétique et puis
c'est aussi la capacité à capter ou à
garder l'eau qui peut tomber en excès on
a bien vu on sait à peu près qu'on est
dans un pays où la quantité d'eau
tombera toujours à peu près la même
annuellement mais avec des périodes où
il y en aura beaucoup et des périodes où
il y en aura moins à nous de réfléchir
aussi comment on peut stocker cette eau
quand il entend beaucoup merci beaucoup
Henri Frémond d'être venu ce soir sur
notre plateau merci bonsoir